POINT STREAK AND SITTING AT 42
GOALS ON THE SEASON TRYING TO
MAKE A>> John: HERE'S SVECHNIKOV
TRIED TO DROP IT BACK.
BROKEN UP BYUNDSON.ECOND TIME FR
THE CANADIENS WHEN THEY LOFTED
IT OVER THE DEFENCE.
>> John: HERE'SROSS.
THERE'S LOWRY DIGGING AWAY.
NOW, THIS SOMEHOW ARE HE'S GOT
TO GET THEEAR FOR HIM.
>> QUICK SHOT RIGHT ON.
MONTEMBEAULT STEERS
EYSSIMONT JUMPED ON THE ICE AND
IT HIT HIS S
HE GETS IT TAK DANCES HIS WAY IA
SHOT OFF THE GLOVE GET THE
OPENING
CONNOR -- PITLICK FED IT TO THE
LINE.
CHOPPED IN BY EDMUNDSON, AND NOW
CLEARED BACK OUT AND KYLE CONON.
>>
LEANS IN.
SCORES!
MORGAN BARRON,
MASON APPLETON.T PASS THROUGH
CROSS-ICE PASS.
DYLAN DeMELO PUTS IT THROUGH
HE HANDS IT OFF.
DROP TO THE POINT. DELAY, COMESK
AND STASTNY FINDS THE SEAM
BETWEEN DEFENSIVERAFFIC IN
FRONT OF HIM YET.
DUBOIS.THAT HAVE WATCHEDEHLING .
CENTRING PASS IN FRONT OUT OF T.
RIGHT BACK
HE LOST CONTROL OF IT WITH DYLAN
DeMELO RIGHT THERE.
DUBOIS THERE AS WELL.
SO IS SVECHNIKOV. BARRON ON HIM.
STASTNY IN TO HELP ICE
SCHMIDT WAS ALL OVERCONNOR FIND-
RIGHT THERE WITH THE PASS OF TO.
PITLICK CAN'T GET IT PAST THE
RED LINE AS APPLETON WILL BATTLE
THEY CAN THANK THEIR GOALTL PLAN
TO THE WING.
GETS THE EMPTY-NET GOAL THAT
SENDS THEM TO THE EXITS WITH
1:29 TO GO.
>> Greg: HE MISSED MORE THAN A
FEW CHANCES